- So Dallas Mavericks owner, Mark Cuban,
says that they aren't going to play
the national anthem before
Mavericks games now,
sparking outrage amongst
lots of people in Texas.
The NBA immediately
responded and said that,
as league rules require,
they have to play the national anthem,
so that more or less is
not government action.
Now leagues occupy a weird liminal space,
but, arguably, these
restrictions are probably fine.
But what isn't fine is that
Texas introduced a bill
to require all sports teams
to play the national anthem.
This is clearly unconstitutional,
it's compelled speech,
you can't do that under
the First Amendment.
Though there is a wrinkle,
they're trying to tie
this to public funding.
Now you can't just say anyone
that receives public funding
must play the national
anthem, but it is possible
that if you tied it to public funding
in the sense that if you take this money
then you must play the national
anthem that might work.
It's not clear if this
law is going to pass
and it should worry anyone
that believes in free speech.
But what do I know? I'm just a lawyer.
So subscribe or I'll see you in court.